ليس انتم ايها الغربيون من
تمتلكون حلفا واحدا من الجيوش
الموحدة للدفاع عن انفسكم. فنحن
سنمتلك حلفا كما تمتلكون. هكذا
يقولها العرب لدول حلف الناتو.
فمن المحيط الاطلسي غربا. وحتى
الخليج العربي شرقا. ثم من
المتوسط شمالا عند تركيا. الى
السودان جنوبا. مرورا بمصر. ستجد
الجميع منخرطين في مشروع بناء
التحالف الذي يختار له الاردن
اسم الناتو بحجة التصدي لاطماع
المشروع الايراني في المنطقة.
وعن اي اطماع تتحدث يا هذا؟ وعن
اي ناتو للعرب هذا الذي تريدون
له ان يكون؟ فان قالوا سيحمون
انفسهم من ايران فمصارين البطن
تتعارك ولكن لا يعالج الداء
بالسم. ما هذا الجنون؟ العرب
يتحدون في جيش واحد مع اسرائيل
بمباركة امريكية. ماذا ستخبرون
سيناء؟ وماذا عن الفلسطينيين؟
ماذا عن المقاومين المدافعين عن
ارضهم؟ لقد تاهت البوصلة العربية
يا سادة. فمن يعيد كفة العرب الى
نصابها؟ كسر البروتوكولات.
تحركات عربية مريبة وزيارات
كثيرة تلوح بحلف عربي. العرب
بدأوا بطرح خلافاتهم جانبا. بدأت
القصة بتصالح سعودي قطري وكسر
خلافات دامت سنوات. ما الذي يجري
في المنطقة يا سادة? ليس ذلك
فقط. بل ظهرت السعودية بزيارة
رسمية الى مصر. وصل ولي العهد
السعودي. وعلى غير العادة هرول
الرئيس المصري عبدالفتاح السيسي
لاستقباله اسفل سلم الطائرة. بن
سلمان اتجه للاردن ليحظى
باستقبال مماثل. لما حدث في
القاهرة. وعن اي حفاوة نتحدث. بن
سلمان وصل زياراته المكوكية
طائرته في تركيا شيء لا يصدق.
اعداء الامس اصدقاء اليوم? لكن
مهلا. اليس هذا امير دولة قطر?
نعم انه هو بشحمه ولحمه. حطت
طائرته في الاراضي المصرية بعد
قطيعة دامت لسنوات. والسيسي يكسر
البروتوكولات مرة اخرى. ويستقبله
بحفاوة وفي المكان ذاته. حيث
استقبل بن سلمان. هذه الزيارة
كانت قبل سنوات قليلة جدا. من
الخيال. السعودية وقطر قطر ومصر
السعودية والاردن. انه زمن تصفية
الخلافات وكسر البروتوكولات. فهل
يطبخ الحلف على نار هادئة?
اتفاقات وتفاهمات ومفاوضات
سعودية ايرانية. زمن الخلافات قد
ولى والمنطقة العربية ترى بعين
اخرى. فما الذي استجد اليوم ايها
العرب? اهي الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية? ام هي ازمة الغذاء
عالمية. ايا يكون السبب فالنتيجة
هي رغبة لشعوب المنطقة. الناتو
العربي. بدأ انشاء فكرة حلف
الناتو العربي بتطبيع الامارات
مع اسرائيل. ثم البحرين مع
اسرائيل يليها تفاهمات قوية
ومشاريع ضخمة بين تركيا واسرائيل
ولم تتوقف هنا. بل وضعت اسرائيل
قدمها في الاراضي العربية. هل
يتوقفون هنا? لا. لن يتوقفوا.
يجب ان يبنوا لهم قواعد دفاع
مشترك في الدول العربية. لا
تستغرب. نعم. لقد وقعت الامارات
والبحرين على اتفاقية دفاع جوي
مشتركة مع اسرائيل وباركت
الولايات المتحدة هذا الزواج غير
الشرعي. يا للعجب. هل نسي ابناء
زايد وصية ابيهم عن اسرائيل حين
قال قاتل الله ديمقراطية
اسرائيل. هل الديموقراطية قتل
الاطفال العزل? اعوذ بالله من
هذه يقال ان اسرائيل ديمقراطيين.
ما دام اسرائيل ديمقراطيين
يقتلون الاطفال ويقتلون النساء
لا عندهم سلاح ولا بايديهم سلاح.
ويهدمون بيوتهم. الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب التقط فكرة عربية
واقترح انشاء نسخة عربية من حلف
شمال الاطلسي. على ان يقوم الحلف
بين دول الخليج ومصر والاردن
بالشراكة مع واشنطن. اما هدفه
فهو معلن وهو التصدي لما يصفونه
بالتوسع الايراني. عبدالله
الثاني ملك الاردن يقول انه يؤيد
نسخة شرق اوسطية من الناتو.
بعدها كشفت عن لقاء عسكري عقد
بشرم الشيخ بمصر ضم عسكريين
امريكيين واسرائيليين بجانب
مصريين واخرين من دول خليجية.
لاستكشاف التنسيق ضد التهديدات
الايرانية. مشروع تحالف الشرق
الاوسط الاستراتيجي. واختصاره في
الترجمة الانجليزية بكلمة او
الناتو العربي. كما اصطلح على
تسميته اعلاميا. يضم دول الخليج
الست بالاضافة الى والاردن. لكن
امريكا تريد لاسرائيل ان تكون
قائدة لهذا الحلف. ما كل هذا
الجنون! قالها جمال عبدالناصر
يوما لبريطانيا التي سهلت دخول
المحتل الاسرائيلي لفلسطين! ده
انتم ولاد ستين كلب! ما اخذ
بالقوة! لا يسترد الا بالقوة!
اما بتطلع الازاعة البريطانية
وبتقول ان جمال عبدالناصر كلب
مسلا زي ما قالوا. بنقول لهم
وانتم ولاد ستين كلب. الولايات
المتحدة ترغب بجيش عربي موحد مع
اسرائيل. ترد الشعوب العربية.
نعم نريد جيشا موحدا. لكن ليس مع
الكيان الاسرائيلي. فكيف للمصري
ان يتشارك مع الاسرائيلي في خندق
واحد. وقد قالها الحسين ملك
الاردن الراحل. اصبروا صابروا.
رابطوا. قاتلوا بايديكم باظافركم
وباسنانكم. اصبروا. اصبروا
صابروا رابطوا. اقتلوهم حيث
وجدتموهم. باسلحتكم بايديكم
باظافركم باسنانكم. فلتنفض غبار
قبرك ايها الملك لتشاهد ما يصنعه
اولادك. هل نسي العرب شهداء
سيناء من جميع الدول العربية? هل
نسي العرب ضحايا الجولان
السورية? هل نسي الجميع اشقائهم
الفلسطينيين الذين يقدمون
ارواحهم ليذودوا عن ارضهم
العربية? حلف الناتو العربي حلم
كل عربي لكن بعيدا عن اعداء
العرب وفي مقدمتهم الكيان
الاسرائيلي يوم ان شاء الامريكان
يطلبون من الملك السعودي فيصل بن
عبد العزيز ان يبيعهم النفط وقفا
لهم بحزم وقال انا رجال كبير في
العمر وعندي امنية ابغى اصلي
ركعتين بالمسجد الاقصى. تقدر
تحقق لي هالامنية? هناك بهت
الامريكان لدعمهم للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يومها. فهل يعيد
العرب الكرة مرة اخرى? وانت
متابعنا. اذا تطوعت يوما في
الجيش بلدك. وفي حلف تعطي كل
دولة مجموعة من جنودها لتعزيز
هذا الحلف. لو وقع الحظ عليك
ليكون قائدك شريط اسرائيلي هل
ستؤدي له التحية العسكرية?